welcome to this video playing I am Alexa
from Israel one of the ICC old times he
is playing on the ICC for you for ages
let's see sometimes you can get an idea
in the finger nose here best blitz
rating 2000 and so this account is at
least 13 years old yeah okay i play on
the SSC since 1997 but with the various
accounts okay this is some his sight
line of the NIMS oh and so let's see if
he knows something about it night f4
this is not very common but probably not
bad so I don't mind the Queen trade in
general he's got the isolated pawn
normally white in the some position
manages to play relatively quickly d5
getting rid of the poem and activating
but yeah this is not so easy in this
specific position
nitey for that he can consider hmm yet
i'm going to take really seems to
improve a structure sometimes taking is
not bad at all because some the hanging
points are also possible weaknesses but
here it doesn't look like it's
convincing to tag now he's preparing d5
let's see can I do that and 97 yeah I
guess I'd like I really like to prevent
t45 at least under favorable
circumstances on d5 I go Knight b6
attacking the bishop and attacking d5
yeah this should be good the question
now is on Bishop d7 yeah probably kill
go d hive the question is is there
something better we should be 75 and I
can treat everything on d5 but at the
end this should be a bit better for
white
Knight takes Knight X everything takes
that the ad the bishop takes on d5 and
she'll probably Bishop c6 we have from
some big simplifications
hmm you know my geforce an alternative
just attacking the bishop okay let's do
that i didn't really calculate that too
much it should be 75 looked like very
one-sided business maybe it wasn't so
dramatic but i'm not sure yeah yeah I
expected that but still okay let's take
that at least it's the bishop pal if I
go five can I go 593 probably but I
cannot play f6 because of d6 check if
I've
93 Bishop d6 not be five hmm maybe f 696
route 26 yeah doesn't look great okay if
I take Knight takes Knight takes Knight
x he's threatening Knight f6 check but I
have Bishop t6 okay let's do that I'm
falling behind on the clock
on the other hand it's very well
possible that with some precise moves
I'm I'm out of the woods this actually
looks quite okay he cannot really okay
Bishop Bishop here right yeah he will
probably double but that's not that's
not really so so dangerous I should
probably just
hmm maybe this one getting out of the
check preparing Bishop c5 they are
Candace this really should be should be
very dry cannot take b6 it's got the
slightly better porn structure because
of the double porn but really not not so
important
50 seconds that's let's more that's more
problem I'm a bit a bit worse but not
not really much
yeah it's basically sit and wait really
nothing active to do him can you know
it's a chick okay okay i am that i
cannot go here that some meat I that was
bad really bad play
ah it smells really bad defense ah it's
um it's really problematic now probably
it's lost okay maybe I can maybe I can
play for hmm maybe check check they form
maybe that's maybe it's enough to hold
but looks very problematic check that's
a draw check check I'm morning gras on
her general Arthur on well this was
probably probably lost at some point the
rock endgame would got very critical it
started with not happening much but then
then I got into trouble oh wow I can
just take p3 here oh wow yeah talk about
first game of the session not saying
that uh I can a hopeful look at at any
point but this is really easy I can just
take the bishop I really forgot that
this is this is possible at all okay
yeah well just winning okay i died i
played this gym now this is much easier
okay
yeah this is just very easy draw okay
yeah and this in fact is maybe I
shouldn't do that but yeah they are here
it's it's a bit bit bit problematic it's
I'm tied to the porn and I'll very often
very often you can give a pawn to to
activate but here that's hardly possible
always after taking b6 he keeps be too
covered and not easy the arm and in the
game I he proved very nicely because
this looks really critical check chan
then maybe here look b5 stronger rugby
five and then g5 but not easy not easy
to see actually the computer now SAS
sequel well equal is not not the real
human term becomes white store yeah it
has this initiative but it seems to
check she seems to fizzle out now after
a form amazed how quickly it check it
challenge was ok again yeah not not a
great game but I'm glad to have defended
this thanks for watching